what's the biggest lesson you learned
about motherhood especially being a
working mom in Hollywood I think the
biggest lessons I'm learning about
motherhood is that the most important
thing is your family they've completely
changed my life in ways like I've always
had a blessed life I've had ups and
downs but with these kids and they're
just such a gift and such a blessing is
there anyone that you can turn to for
advice especially another maybe famous
mother who know who knows exactly the
grinder up against oh well I mean Jess
Alba was like you know I think always on
speed dial for me I you know always
called her and and I think of in our
lifestyle the way that we have to live
it's so different it's very different
and it's not as easy to navigate and she
does it so elegantly and seamlessly and
so I'm very very lucky and then when I I
remember asking her like how did you do
that
like I've even believed like ìhow do i
can't believe like you like it
then none of our friends had kids right
do you have any piece of advice for
making Fox we just confirmed that she's
actually pregnant with her third child
you're outnumbered now girl I think that
the more the merrier